few franchises blur reality and fantasy
as successfully as Transformers here's
what these behemoths of special effects
look like without all the digital
Wizardry
Autobots roll out big complicated
transforming robots seem a little common
today there are seven feature
Transformers films now and countless
technological imitators but when 2007's
Transformers hit the big screen both the
scale and intricacy of the robot effects
was something audiences hadn't really
seen before while the original cartoons
of the robots looking fairly simple
director Michael baay has always
endeavored to make them more each has
hundred or thousands of complex moving
parts and effects designers have gone to
excruciating lens to make every part of
each robot move and transform in a way
that would work in the real world that
takes testing and retesting for example
if you look at the Transformers highway
Battle Before the CGI has been fully
rendered you can see how many steps it
actually took to bring everything to
life an incomplete render of the road
robots helps designers perfect the scene
thus having to do 100% of the work for
each attempt this step allows them to
rehearse a scene over and over to see
what works and what doesn't they can
choreograph the fight adjust movements
or even entire elements and study the
angles to get proper lighting and
Reflections this all helps to make sure
they're interacting believably with the
surrounding photography as well as onset
props actors and vehicles the second
film in The Saga Transformers Revenge of
the Fallen introduced several new ideas
to the series including the Bold
decision to film it without a script we
were given a date we were given a bunch
of money we were given a bunch of toys
and we had no script the movie also
introduced a Decepticon known as a
pretender which disguises itself by
taking the form of a young woman named
Alice while in Sam's dorm Alice reveals
her true nature with her face opening up
to reveal robot paths before her entire
body transforms there were two different
effects in the scene the robotic tongue
that wraps around Sam's neck was a mix
of CGI and a physical prop for the
digital effects actress Isabelle Lucas
first set to be filmed acting out all of
the pretenders movements both before and
after she transformed with this to work
with artists at digital domain were able
to Overlay CGI depicting The Pretenders
robot elements erasing parts of Lucas's
body as needed until nothing was left it
begins with cracks appearing across her
face before she opens her mouth to
reveal a robot and more parts of her
head expand and open as a true self
emerges It's a combination of multiple
layers of CGI and it all combines to
create a convincing
monstrosity acting opposite digital
characters takes a lot of imagination
something Megan Fox had to contem with
when making Revenge of the Fallen that
film added a pair of pint-sized
Decepticons named wheie and brains and
in one pivotal scene her character
Michaela is able to capture one of them
after catching willly lurking she grabs
hold of the Decepticon with a pair of
tongues who struggles and squirms in her
grasp this time though the actress had
no replica to work with what this meant
was that in the rock footage Fox was
battling pretty much nothing she just
shakes a blue object in her tongues and
acts like she's struggling it may look
silly on its own but when the CGI artist
add in wheie it all comes together in
film making the art of special effects
has come a long way since the early days
story boards were and still remain one
of the most useful tools for planning a
scene with scene sketches to show how
the camera should be positioned and how
the action flows but thanks to CGI
digital sequences called animatics can
be created as crude versions of the
final seen in its entirety using quick
3D mockups of the environment and
characters this prev visualization or
previs has become a critical component
in making CGI heavy movies like
Transformers to plan the forest scene in
Revenge of the Fallen for example an
early render of Optimus Prime was
quickly assembled to give filmmakers an
idea of what the scene might look like
it allows them to set up the camera and
move it through the scene while the
characters play out their parts the
entire sequence involved a highly
choreographed fight scene between
multiple Transformers and this pre pre
allowed Michael Bay to get precise
movements planned out well in advance
previous is an awesome tool but to bring
a scene to life you need to put it in
the real world background photography is
one of the most important steps to
Michael Bay when putting together the
most exciting shots of the Transformers
films having those real backgrounds
helped sell the scene and for Revenge of
the Fallen that Forest battle between
Optimus Prime and Megatron in the forest
was one of the most complex to get right
that meant lots of pre-planning which
allowed ba and his team to plan ahead to
get what they needed on location
according to a behind the-scenes
featurette this sequence was pretty dang
tricky to create as described by VFX
Specialists Michael Bay wanted an
incredibly kinetic battle happening in
the scene which meant changing the way
the robots moved and fought some of this
feels a little uh stylized because we
had referenced a lot of anime fight
sequences when we started out but has
massive robots the size of small
buildings every move they make would
kick up dirt or knock down trees an
initial pass would capture or boil down
to an invisible battle tearing up the
landscape later the Transformers were
added in time to the movement smoke and
dirt that was staged during the shooting
with so many CGI characters in The
Transformers movies it can often be a
struggle to convince the audience that
the human characters are side by side
with their robot counterparts come to
death to create this illusion filmmakers
use many different methods while
shooting scenes that involve both humans
and robots sometimes it's a fully
constructed robot replica or a piece of
them at at least which allows actors to
physically interact with the real object
other times there's simply nothing there
at all for at least one scene in Revenge
of the Fallen a production assistant
simply held up a cardboard cutout off
the head of the robot character this is
typically used for scenes that don't
require direct interaction but it gives
the actors a reference point to make a
consistent eyeline without it actors
like shy La buff and Megan Fox could be
looking all over the place never quite
sure of where Bumblebee's face was with
something as simple as a cardboard head
on a stick they can give believable
response aners to a character that isn't
there when it comes to stand-ins for
Transformer characters sometimes a
cardboard head on a stick just isn't
enough for the making of Revenge of the
Fallen a scene required Shila Buff to
get up on top of Optimus Prime's body to
Sab him with the Matrix the filmmaker
could have simply had him stand on a
platform or even just use clever camera
angles to make it seem like he was
standing on Prime's body but production
created a crude full size stand in for
Optimus
[Music]
Prime
is it really a Michael Bay movie without
at least one scene of devastating
roadway bem we don't know Michael Bay
never gives us a chance to find out I'm
never going to be doing another highway
chase again all right let's go try one
shall we the Transformer series
obviously relies on CGI more than most
movies but you might be surprised to
learn how much of the action in the
Transformers movies was created on set
from flipping cars and exploding
buildings to even some of the robots
themselves in one sequence in
Transformers Dark of the Moon deceptic
cons and Autobots Chase each other down
a busy highway and as they race down the
road chaos and faults while the
Transformers themselves are entirely CGI
and added in later behind the scenes
footage shows a massive blue painted
truck with a plow being used as a
standin to physically smash through cars
eventually the truck was digitally
erased and replaced with the
Transformers additional CGI elements
like debris smoke and bigger Flames at
further excitement to the sequence
Transformers Dark of the Moon one UPS
the previous two films in many ways
particularly in terms of pure spectacle
the Decepticons lead an allout attack on
the city of Chicago which sends entire
skyscrapers tumbling to the street below
one of the key settings drawing the
battle to take back the city is inside a
skyscraper leading at a precarious angle
the wide exterior shuts for a digital
creation but going pure digital or
filming inside a real skyscraper and
using visual trickery for all of the
action going on inside wasn't good
enough instead Bay had a team construct
an entire floor of an office building on
a moving gimbal that could tilt the
entire thing back and forth that
platform is onethird of a football field
the gimbal is a large apparatus that can
swing to and frow allowing baay to
adjust the exact angle he wanted to send
the actors sliding down the rig gimbals
are common enough in films is how some
of the gravity shift effects in
Inception were achieved for one but
rarely if ever has one been used for an
entire office building floor in behind
the scenes footage from the movie you
really get a sense of just how big this
set is as the creu sets it up for
different scenes and it was more than
just an interior set when the team jumps
out the windows on the top side of the
Leaning structure they end up in an
uncontrolled slide down the windows
again this sequence was done without the
use of CGI well without too much CGI but
making it happen was surprisingly simple
they just did it for real using the same
gimbal platform production placed real
glass panes on the outside and wax them
to a slippery finish and send the actors
down as fast as they could go this 110t
glass slide he had them sprinkle baby
powder on their rear ends so that they
would scoot down even faster there are
several options filmmakers can use to
create an otherworldly landscape in a
sci-fi film they can shoot in a real
location and place their CGI
Transformers in the scene and post
production or they can create the entire
environment with computer generated
imagery the third option is a hybrid of
the two and involves large sets or
locations where digital imagery is used
to alter the real Landscapes to create
the interior of lock down ship in Age of
Extinction a massive interior was
constructed on an indoor Sound Stage
complete with smoke machines fireballs
and lighting to create the overall mood
with this real life starting point the
FX team at industrial Light and Magic
could start working their industrial
Light and Magic beyond the physically
constructed set pieces green screen
walls gave the team visual indicators
they could use to turn the set into a
sprawling Starship interior hundreds and
hundreds of feet long and populated by
enormous alien robots part of the genius
of the physical design was that since
this is supposed to be a somewhat
militarized alien spaceship they were
able to build modular pieces that could
be moved around to create different
sections of the ship while maintaining
the same texture and feel throughout the
impressive combination of both real and
digital Artistry put into this set
definitely stands out even in a
franchise filled with such things we're
Behind Enemy Lines now lockdown ship has
booby trapped it's not uncommon for a
director to make a cameo in their movie
whether it's Peter Jackson belting at
the camera and Lord of the Rings or
Alfred Hitchcock appearing in well most
of his movies spotting these little
Easter eggs is a lot of fun for fans and
in Age of Extinction Michael B got a
tiny Cameo thanks to a little visual
effects Wizardry the moment comes during
a battle between Autobots and
Decepticons on the open road and an
Optimus Prime goes flying through the
back of a truck eagley viewers can spot
Bae as a panicked
passenger genius No ba wasn't riding in
that truck while it got blasted to
Smither his footage was filmed in front
of a green screen and composite Ed into
the main shot in the editing room it's a
tough Cameo to spot but it's one of
those things that would you notice it
can't be unseen the Transformers movies
obviously take a lot of pride in using
as much practical photography as
possible Michael Bay will film Real
roads cars and buildings and even have
the landscape smashed up and destroyed
to help ground all the CGI that gets
added later because it's one thing to
animate a realistic CGI robot but if
it's not interacting with the
environment in a relatively normal way
it's hard to suspend your disbelief but
it's not structures and vehicles are
real in the frame it's usually a mix of
the two but CGI used to give onset
elements a different look few set pieces
showcase are better than the wide scale
destruction during the climax of age of
Extinction throughout the sequence lockd
Down's big magnet is constantly riging
objects down onto the city below and
much of that Carnage was indeed captured
by hoisting Vehicles into the air on
wires and then dropping them I just like
moving big things very close to the
camera to keep it real but of behind the
scenes glimpse from industrial Light to
magic shows how much work was done in
post- production the ship itself is
obviously a digital creation as are the
ccraft falling onto the road even the
car varying the characters out of danger
is digital in this shart later an
entirely different background of the
city was added behind the action and
several large pieces of infrastructure
were removed from the frame the end
result is a near seamless mix of real
life destruction and impossible alien
machines that would make you shout oh my
God
some directors are happy to sit behind
the camera call Action and cut Michael
Bay however is not that kind of director
he's always in the middle of the action
and never afraid to roll up his sleeves
and get his hands a little dirty my
director would kill him man for fun look
at any behind the-scenes footage from
any of the Transformers movies and it's
clear how involved ba is in every aspect
of filming whether he's personally
manipulating shy La Buff's face to mimic
a robot or menacing Nicola Pelt with a
green robot claw it's clearly tough to
get actors to convincingly react to
robots that aren't there but ba is
always up to the challenge while the
movies may have their faults it's hard
enough to appreciate Ba's Devotion to
nailing every single shot of his
Transformers films due to Michael Ba's
propensity for shooting real elements
there a certain grittiness to the
Transformers movies with so much CGI the
use of real backgrounds helps ground the
scene in ways CGI extensions can't
always achieve and although B bowed out
of directing the spin-off movie
Bumblebee a lot of those techniques will
still used to bring the film to life to
film bumblebee stumbling through a
smoldering set for example director
Travis Knight got as much of the scening
camera as possible the Baseline fires
and wreckage are all real although
multiple extra layers were then added to
build up the atmosphere assembled in
post production it shows how a few
little changes to a scene can help sell
the illusion of reality demonstrating
the true magic of special effects
sometimes all you need is a light to
touch to bring a single scene to life on
the flip side of that some scenes like
the action on Cybertron were completely
digital though it's true that the
Transformers are created entirely on a
computer that doesn't mean they weren't
actually there on set at all well what
we see on screen is indeed CGI full
scale physical models of some robot
characters were created for some scenes
more than just a simple prop the head
shoulders and torso of Bumblebee were
built at full scale and used around the
set for a variety of purposes a standin
like this can prove useful for setting
up camera angles lighting and staging
scenes but it's also crucial for the
actor's performances with a physical
representation of Bumblebee there cast
members like Haley Steinfeld could have
a real life scene partner to interact
with providing not just an eyeline but a
physical body that she can see touch and
act opposite allows for a sense of
realness and believability that is
otherwise difficult to achieve often
when discussing the behindth scenes
efforts to create the elaborate effects
works on movies like bumblebee you'll
hear how a physical element was removed
and replaced with a CGI creation but
it's not as simple of process as that
makes it sound it takes a number of
distinct steps and hours of painstaking
digital Artistry just to set up and even
more intense work to get just right are
you
[Music]
scared for this scene in which Charlie
is standing over bumblebee in a forest
we can see three of those distinct
setups for an over the-shoulder shot
Steinfeld was looking at a sheet of
green screen fabric lying on the ground
from there the digital animators could
build out a rough model of Bumblebee
that's ultimately replaced by the full
digital render for the wi shots the
handy Bumble toop came into play again
and was again erased to bring the
digital bumblebee to life set extensions
are a key component to making movies
these days as digital effects can turn
any real life location into something
it's not impossible it's a common tool
even in movies where you wouldn't expect
to see a lot of VFX sometimes sets can
be extended without the help of blue or
green screens but those tools certainly
make the work easier and often this
means constructing massive wall walls of
blue or green fabric to help special
effects teams to mask out the background
and work their magic that technique was
used in Transformers rise of the Beast
to build up the exterior of the museum
set set in 1994 rise of the Beast as a
prequel to The earlier films and shows
Optimus Prime in his classic Mac Truck
form in one of the key action scenes he
arrives at a museum at the start of an
allout Robo brawl between the autobots
and the Terra cons as he enters his shot
we can see the museum in the background
the large Blue structure at top it and
behind it for the battle outside the
museum the lowest level of the museum
was physically built while a massive
blue screen wall stood in on set for the
upper levels of the structure MPC was
one of the VFX companies responsible for
digitally finishing the set not to
mention the robots fighting in it in the
final film the museum is much different
which no doubt made it a lot easier to
progressively destroy throughout the
fight part of the magic of editing is
the ability to shoot scenes on different
sets sometimes even different countries
and weave them together so it looks like
the ACT ction is all happening in one
place while the autobots and terac cons
are juking it out outside the museum in
Rise of the Beast Noah and Museum intern
Elena are dealing with their own
problems inside Scourge uses a blaster
to blow holes in the face of the museum
sending Noah and Elena running for cover
while the room explodes around them to
film that scene the interior of the
museum was built and then blasted apart
with pyrot Technics while cameras
captured the action the final scene is
just seconds of screen time but it's
clear that plenty of time and effort was
taken to create this single over the top
moment so you want to put a high stakes
car chase in your movie there are a
couple ways that could happen you could
Scout the perfect real life location and
shut down half a city to get the shots
you could go the route of the Matrix
Reloaded and just build your own Highway
set or you can blend a real location
with digital effects to get the best of
both worlds that's how production
achieved a nail-biting police chase in
Rise of the Beast which sent Noah a
mirage kening through the streets of NYC
and across the Williamsburg Bridge the
scene was filmed partly on real streets
but for the sections on the bridge a
little digital trickery came into play
Massive stretches of blue screen were
erected on either side of a road to
provide coverage and blocking for CGI
artists to add in the bright lights and
Tall skyscrapers effect house MPC did
the work of building in every digital
layer for the scene further integrating
mirage's unique Transformations into the
foreground the final version of the shot
in the film has nowhere racing across a
bridge with a panorama of the city
skyline in the
background with as many diverse
locations as seen across the
Transformers movies it can be a
challenge for filmmakers to find new and
original places to film over the years
the franchise has gone everywhere from
rural Texas to the pyramids of Egypt and
everywhere in between where are we
D we're actually at Disney World uh at
the Egyptian part of the theme park come
on but some scenes need specific
conditions and characteristics that
prove a bit too challenging to find in
the real world for those locations
producers usually opt to create them on
a downstage and thanks to the magic of
special effects can make them feel even
more real the Labyrinth thine
underground temple in rides of the Beast
was one set where a Sound Stage was
utilized the base of the set was built
with blue screens added so animators
could easily give the cave well more
rocks okay so maybe it's not the biggest
CGI challenge we've seen in these films
but every little Touch goes towards
making the final product and when it's
all put together it creates a fully
believable immersive location that
audiences would never know was built
inside an empty Warehouse
interactions on screen between humans
and robots in Transformers movies can be
tricky at the easiest of moments at the
toughest it can seem downright
impossible the easiest way to get around
that is to not just have your real and
digital characters physically interact
but what if a scene describes a 30ft
tall Optimus Prime lifting a teenager
off the ground and holding him in
midair not
cool to make it seem like Prime was
holding Noah 10 ft off the ground actor
Anthony Ramos was strapped into an
elaborate crane rig and suspended in the
air while cameras film The Action from
various angles then digital animators
added in Optimus in all his glory and
voila you have the impossible made
[Music]
possible